[Música]
Hola bienvenidos al debate de France 24
en español Soy Santiago aristía y estará
reemplazando por esta oportunidad a mi
compañero Santiago López tras semanas de
liberaciones y varias rondas de votación
Reino Unido tiene nueva primera ministra
la sucesora de Boris Johnson y nueva
líder del partido conservador es listros
quien ejercía como secretaria de
relaciones exteriores ella obtuvo el 57%
de los votos de los miembros del partido
para hacer la premiere de Reino Unido a
Trust Le tocará gobernar en tiempos
difíciles llega al mando del Ejecutivo
en un contexto donde sobran los desafíos
hablamos por ejemplo de lidiar con una
crisis energética Un aumento constante
del costo de vida el levantamiento de
huelgas por parte de trabajadores de
varios sectores además de deudas
pendientes que sigue dejando el brexit
entre muchos otros temas y para analizar
todos estos temas nos acompañan
Sepúlveda ella es cientista política y
también Leslie benac Venegas profesor de
ciencia política de la Universidad de
Reino Unido les recuerdo que ustedes a
nuestra audiencia también hacen parte de
esta conversación dejen sus preguntas y
también todos sus comentarios en
nuestras redes sociales estamos en
Twitter Instagram y Facebook donde nos
encuentran como arroba france24 guión
bajo es y arroba Santiago arístides mi
cuenta personal la etiqueta es numeral
el debate f24 mientras que en YouTube
pueden Seguir nuestra señal en streaming
saludamos a las personas que nos
escuchan en nuestro podcast y los invito
para que escuchen todos los contenidos
de nuestro programa que está disponible
en Apple podcast Spotify deezer y tuning
y ahora si comenzamos a dialogar con
nuestros invitados Carmen Sepúlveda
bienvenida Muchísimas gracias por su
participación en el debate de France 24
en español bueno el proceso de elección
enfrentó a truars y también al ex
ministro de economía
Por qué cree que eligieron finalmente a
litros
creo que el perfil de listas Es
simplemente más amigable se veía menos
elitista hay un cierto voto conservador
que No necesariamente viene Don Elite
que es el que seguramente votó fueron
las bases que apoyaron a listas mientras
que a rishizuna lo habían apoyado las
élites del partido los empites lo que os
ponen pies los ponían pies muy
diferentes de durante esta durante esta
competencia
pero yo creo que ella proyectaba la idea
de ser una mujer común y corriente a
través de una historia muy simple de una
familia simple y avanzar los escalones
de la jerarquía del partido de modo muy
meritocrático cuando a recibir una se le
vio una imagen de un niño rico un niño
que tuvo la oportunidad de estudiar se
casó con alguien con una fortuna aún
mayor y trabajando en finanzas digamos
dar una perspectiva muy débil muy lejana
al inglés común y corriente que Quizás
votatorio vamos ahora con Leslie benac
Venegas le agradecemos a usted también
por supuesto su presencia en el debate
de France 24 en español y le traslado la
misma pregunta por qué cree que es
listos fue finalmente El Elegido la
primera ministra
Hola buenas noches gracias por la
invitación Bueno fue en parte elegía por
lo que ya señaló mi colega
Pero creo que es como se proyecta y se
presenta ella dentro de el partido
conservador ante las bases del partido
conservador y la promesa de generar
ciertas políticas que buscan reducir el
tamaño del Estado generar ciertas
reforma reducir la tasa impositaria que
creo que
eso es bien recibido por la base
electoral de el partido conservador sin
embargo eso es bastante distinto a una
vez que llega hoy va a llegar a ejercer
el rol de primera ministra
bueno listos es la tercera mujer que
llega al cargo de primera ministra de
Reino Unido luego de margaret thatcher y
Teresa mayne y asumen cuando el país se
tambalea de crisis en crisis tras el
voto del brexit echemos un vistazo a
continuación al ascenso de listos
dio un golpe de gracia a su rival y sube
al escenario reclamando ser la heredera
de Margarita Cherry es el legado implica
recortar sino frenar el poder de los
sindicatos y reducir los impuestos
tengo un plan para convertir a Reino
Unido en una economía de alto
crecimiento en los próximos 10 años
mediante una Audaz reforma de oferta
reduciremos los impuestos ayudando a las
empresas a invertir en su futuro
abordaremos el coste de la energía y
controlaremos el gasto Público
de asuntos exteriores de Reino Unido los
últimos tres años en este cargo hizo una
serie de declaraciones controvertidas
una de ellas recientemente cuando se le
preguntó por el presidente francés
presidente macron amigo o Enemigo El
Jurado abandonó la sala
Los lazos con los vecinos europeos
fueron el quiebre de táchira y han sido
durante mucho tiempo motivo de tensión
en el partido conservador tres voto a
favor de la permanencia en la Unión
Europea en 2016 pero en las elecciones
de líderes de este verano dijo que se
había equivocado una señora a favor de
los giros en U esta mujer de 47 años
comenzó su vida política como liberal
demócrata mientras estudiaba en la
universidad de Oxford y apoyó la
legalización del Cannabis y La abolición
de la monarquía sin embargo llegó a ser
diputada conservadora ocupando seis
carteras ministeriales bajo tres
primeros ministros
sucede a Boris Johnson con el Reino
Unido luchando por encontrar su camino
después de un brexit desordenado una ola
de huelgas infracción de dos dígitos y
el partido laborista por delante de las
encuestas no muy diferente de cuando
Tacher llegó al poder hace décadas
y ahora sí retomamos el diálogo y la
comunicación con nuestros invitados
expertos Carmen Sepúlveda bueno quisiera
preguntarle en primer lugar Cómo
caracterizaría el perfil de listras para
muchos no es una conservadora
tradicional pasó del partido demócrata
liberal fue una férrea opositora a la
monarquía también
creo que
a ver
algunos lo considerarían pragmática
otros considerarían que tiene poco
anclaje ideológico
yo creo que sus conexiones ideológicas
son bastante flexibles claramente si uno
pasa de tres partidos desde que joven
Hasta ahora se convierte primero el
ministro de un partido que no estaba
digamos en esa línea original
tiene la capacidad de decirlo correcto
en el momento correcto tiene la
capacidad de negociar y avanzar algunos
miembros del partido
conservador como Rod Stewart declararon
que sabía siempre decirlo lo Exacto en
el lugar exacto y era muy disciplinada a
nivel político con el líder que le
tocaba por encima lo que le permitió
ascender muy rápidamente Dónde están los
afones del partido por lo tanto algunos
en francés no se dice eso
es capaz de voltear rápidamente para
conseguir lo que necesita y y en ese
aspecto lo que recién comentaban el voto
por ejemplo por la Unión Europea Porque
allá por salir de la Unión Europea de
brexit fue claro O sea ella estaba
absolutamente a favor de quedarse dentro
de la Unión Europea y resulta que ahora
le tuvo con la para poder conseguir ese
voto popular ese voto más conservador
que decir que no que no que en realidad
ella se equivocó cosa que yo no creo no
creo que ella se si se haya equivocado
bueno precisamente sobre este punto Le
quiero preguntar no de su vínculo con la
Unión Europea que puede llegar a suceder
no han habido tensiones entre el bloque
y Reino Unido de hecho listroce fue una
de las personas que promovió no una ley
que permitiría incumplir acuerdos del
brexit me refiero a algunas normativas
vinculadas a Irlanda del Norte no poder
tomar algunas medidas unilaterales por
parte de Reino Unido teniendo esto en
cuenta lo que usted hacía referencia
recién que podemos esperar de los
vínculos con la Unión Europea
Se podrían deteriorar aún más está claro
yo creo que la posición del grupo que
ella quería seducir en este voto que es
un grupo más de extrema derecha quiere
que haya un desapego total con no
solamente con la Unión Europea per sé
pero con ciertos a ver símbolos de la
relación con Europa por ejemplo como la
convención Europea de derechos humanos
de la cual ella se quiere salir ella no
cree en eso y por algo puso a la próxima
ministra del interior ahora que resignó
la actual
Azuela breverman la puso para que por
favor
terminara con ese proceso Entonces está
por un lado eso por otro lado lo que
también vimos recién su relación con
macron y ya se deterioró antes que
incluso partiera todo esto
va Yo creo que va a ser capaz de decir
cosas también que quizás van a incomodar
mucho la relación entre la Unión Europea
y el Reino Unido Y eso también
nos lleva de que Escocia por ejemplo Que
si se mantiene muy cercano todavía la
Unión Europea va a tener muchos
conflictos probablemente con listas
quisiera trasladarle la misma pregunta a
usted qué podría ocurrir entre los
vínculos entre Reino Unido y la Unión
Europea con listos como primera ministra
del país
yo creo que bueno van a ser ella tiene
18 meses de mandato creo que antes día
que asuma a manifestado una serie de
posibles medidas sobre todo con el caso
del protocolo de Irlanda del Norte
y eso ha generado una atención bastante
fuerte con la Unión Europea con la
comisión pero también con relaciones
bilaterales específicamente con con
Manuel macron
ahora vamos a abordar otro punto clave
no Porque litros llega al cargo tras una
serie de escándalos y de polémicas no
que envolvieron al ex Primer Ministro
Boris Johnson hablamos por supuesto de
una catarata de renunciar tras la salida
a la luz de un escándalo de acoso sexual
en el que se ve involucrado un
parlamentario muy cercano a él esto
después de que enfrentar además una
moción de censura no cuando se
conocieron fotos pruebas de
celebraciones en la sede del gobierno
mientras el país estaba confinado por la
pandemia de Kobe 19 y listo se mantuvo
siempre con un firme de apoyo a Johnson
A diferencia de sunac cierto y sin
embargo fue elegida creen que fue esa
lealtad precisamente la que definió su
elección quizás
primero a usted a Carmen yo creo que sí
En parte sí supo hacer
política muy interesante logró poner a
cuenta de sunarp todas las debilidades y
errores que había cometido el gobierno
Johnson sin ella atacar directamente a
Johnson sino que atacan dos una ex
diciendo usted estaba en ese gobierno
usted también en el fondo
promovió que cayera el Primer Ministro
por lo tanto usted se hace responsable y
eso es es una transferencia ahí de
culpabilidad bastante interesante que le
permitió a ella destacarse sin romper su
vínculo yo creo con el grupo de Johnson
ella no nunca ha Renegado de su relación
con Johnson y mucha gente especula que
no se ha alejado tampoco mucho de hecho
la gente que va a entrar ahora al
gobierno con ella son del grupo de una
derecha bien conservadura conservadora
cercanos también a Johnson y a otros
personeros de su de su gobierno
de traslado la misma pregunta a Leslie
qué opina al respecto esa lealtad aboris
Johnson quizá fue lo que le aseguró ser
la primera ministra
yo creo que en parte sí
en parte está está ese aspecto Pero
también es la es la promesa que ella
quiere ejecutar de como líder y a
diferencia de richizuna y yo creo que
las medidas que promete para para la
base conservadora No necesariamente eso
resuena y genera simpatía a nivel
nacional en el resto del electorado pero
para llegar al poder para llegar a ese
rol ella promete una serie de medidas Y
es ahí hace una diferencia bastante
fuerte con con lo que promete richizuna
que él promete cierta medida un poco más
más dura
tras habla de reducir la tasa impositiva
para para los distintos
para la gente del partido para la gente
para el electorado en general no ahora
esa esa yo creo que ella ella adopta una
posición bastante inteligente de no
comprometerse no no verbaliza mucho
cuando
cae bori Johnson Y eso es lo que habla
Carmen también
que delega tácitamente esa
responsabilidad esa culpabilidad a
rechinar Carmen Carmen
una simpatía y un apoyo desde No
necesariamente desde Boris Johnson pero
sí de los que están alrededor de él
Ahora sí Carmen vuelvo con usted porque
hay un amplio sector que espera cambios
no respecto de lo que fue el mandato del
ex Premier Boris Johnson quizás se
podría dar bueno teniendo en cuenta toda
esta lealtad de la que hablábamos no
detrás a Johnson se podría dar sin
embargo un giro con respecto a la
política del ex Primer Ministro
yo no creo que va a haber un giro tan
grande yo creo que va a haber una
profundización en ciertas áreas
el anuncio por ejemplo nuevamente del
tema migratorio es ir más allá de lo que
tenemos en este momento que ya era
terrible con la idea de mandar a los a
los que pedían asilo de vueltas a África
a Ruanda pasando llevar convenciones de
Derechos Humanos por un lado está eso lo
otro Es que llevamos desde el 2010 con
Cameron
políticas de hostería muy severas en la
economía inglesa y esas políticas de
austeridad Se podrían llevar aún más
allá siendo de que estamos en una crisis
económica ahora la la creencia detrás de
esto es que el crecimiento va a
automáticamente redistribuir un
bienestar para la sociedad cosa que no
está haciendo así ya que los recortes
presupuestarios que se han hecho las
políticas públicas sociales en
Inglaterra han dejado mucha gente
en situaciones de mayor dificultad
además covid
con 24 hoy día salió sin ir más allá en
canal cuatro una una encuesta que decía
que 24 millones de los 67 millones de
personas del Reino Unido van a tener que
usar menos gas y electricidad y 19
millones ya están evitando usar sus
autos o desplazarse si no es necesario
para ahorrar otros 16 millones están
recortando sus presupuestos alimenticios
y están usando bancos de alimentación
Esa es la Inglaterra la que nos estamos
enfrentando en este momento por lo tanto
yo creo que se podría profundizar una
austeridad que podría llevar a más
problemas ahora bien el cambio que se
puede producir ahora y que es
interesante es que el partido laborista
ha subido en las encuestas y para eso
quizás estén obligados a hacer ayudas
directas a los ciudadanos para poder
paliar
las dificultades de la crisis energética
y eso está por verse pero en el Times
cuasi cuartel que va a ser su chancelot
allá anunció que si es posible que hagan
esas ayudas
precisamente vinculado a esto en su
discurso de Victoria's anunció que
entregará un plan para reducir los
impuestos para bueno para hacer crecer a
la economía su respuesta a esta crisis
será clave verdad pero quisiera
preguntarle Leslie que tanto margen de
maniobra tendrá listo hasta que margen
de acción para poder encarar y responder
de esta manera a esta crisis de que
viene estaba describiendo Carmen
viviendo Carmen Sí bueno la crisis es
bastante es bastante fuerte
creo que el margen de tiempo que ella
tiene 18 meses es bastante es bastante
poco y en ese sentido ella tiene que
Mostrar resultados inmediatos ahora la
serie de medidas que ella promete no sé
si vayan necesariamente hacer la
solución
y eso obviamente
eso genera va a generar una equipación
política más fuerte en el país sobre
todo al hablar de reducir los derechos
de los sindicatos
al reducir impuestos obviamente eso
genera un impacto
inmediato pero la parte redistributiva
de esas medidas económicas van a estar
pendientes eso no se sabe mucho si
existen cualquier tipo de medidas
redistributivas ella va a generar para
paliar la crisis energética la inflación
y obviamente para aliviar
la situación económica de muchas
familias
Carmen coincide usted con Leslie con
este análisis de que este plan de listos
no solo no no resolverá la crisis sino
que quizás podría agudizarla en algunos
aspectos
yo creo que en general las medidas que
puede llegar a tomar este gobierno sí va
a agudizar mucho la condición económica
del país es muy probable porque apostar
a por ejemplo al tema del crecimiento en
este momento cuando sabemos que hay una
crisis mayor a nivel global es un nivel
de inseguridad gigante
[Música]
no soy economista no te podría ir
discutir más allá pero lo que sí sé y
entiendo es que la deuda pública en
Inglaterra sigue siendo alta de que la
libra se ha visto afectada por estos
temas y todo eso va a tener un Impacto
otro tema conflictivo que va a tener que
enfrentar listos huelgas y un malestar
social no hablamos de diversos sectores
de trabajadores que en los últimos días
y también para los próximos ha convocado
a huelgas no hablamos de trabajadores
del sector por ejemplo de la empresa de
correos del país estibadores
trabajadores ferroviarios muchos
descontentos con sus condiciones
salariales laborales genera confianza o
Esperanza Trump entre los trabajadores o
por el contrario su lineamiento a Boris
Johnson le jugaría en contra
vamos con usted Perdón nuevamente
Perdón
no Mira yo creo que está súper claro lo
dejó en un Twitter hoy Jeremy corven que
salieron una foto con Mickey que ha
estado cierto liderando mucha de estas
huelgas en el que ya decía nos estamos
preparando para un
no esa idea que también sucedió los 70
no de que se vino Tuvo una época cercana
en octubre en noviembre hacia el
invierno
de manifestaciones de protestas en que
los movimientos sindicales se
organizaron y se movieron ahora estamos
en un contexto postal activista en el
cual los derechos sindicales se han
reducido a casi un mínimo el tipo de
huelga que hay hoy en día no es lo que
tenían lo que se enfrentó a tache porque
Tacher anuló de hecho el poder de los
sindicatos entonces
van van yo creo tener que ser muy
creativos también los sindicatos para el
como lo fueron durante el verano que
entorpecieron el viaje de la gente a las
vacaciones para llamar la atención del
gobierno y hacerle sentir realmente es
el peso de su de su de sus acciones
a ustedes este futuro en las relaciones
entre litros y el sector de trabajadores
de muchísimos ámbitos que se han estado
manifestando como decía previamente
yo creo que las promesas que ella ha
hecho en cuanto a medidas económicas y a
medida sociales creo que no ayudan
sinceramente yo creo que eso genera una
distancia mucho más fuerte entre entre
los de los movimientos sindicales y lo
que promete el partido conservador
Johnson a pesar de que él salió y entró
en crisis y lo sacaron del poder algo
que él sí generó Más allá de la
sustancia de la medida fue la idea de
emparejar la cancha ya la sustancia de
esa política no están no tan cara pero
La retórica de generar una mayor
intervención del Estado Mayor hija de
ayudas sociales creo que eso lo ayudó
sobre todo en el contexto de pandemia Y
eso actualmente no se ve con la promesa
de Liz Rush y eso obviamente va a
aumentar el descontento social
y obviamente también el descontento de
los de los poderes sindicales
Leslie hablemos ahora de las divisiones
entre los Stories porque a la nueva
Premier también esperan desafíos a nivel
político por supuesto No de hecho este
largo proceso que duró tres meses
aproximadamente para reemplazar a líder
de Downey Street mostró divisiones no al
interior de la formación teniendo en
cuenta que tendrá la no simple tarea no
deformar Un gobierno como prevé Leslie
este proceso puede listos terminar con
esas divisiones O al menos al menos
amenizarlas digo mediar
va a depender de qué de qué rol va a
jugar richizonates ya sea en el en el
gabinete o desde atrás
en el parlamento qué rol va a jugar
Boris Johnson
qué peso tiene el legado de Johnson
actualmente
creo que parte de las medidas de de Luis
tras en términos económicos y en
términos políticos bueno son 18 meses en
los cuales en 18 meses más va a haber
una lección y si los miembros del
partido no la ven
generando confianza generando apoyo y
movilización de votantes para una
reelección y una mayoría del partido
conservador yo creo que obviamente eso
va a erosionar su poder interno
Carmen cómo evaluó a usted de este
asunto de cara sobre todo a lo que es la
formación de un gobierno no podrá atrás
mediar entre estas divisiones entre los
Stories
No logré escuchar a mi colega pero
espero no repetir
yo creo que trozo va a tener que caminar
una cuerda floja para tener que caminar
una cuarta muy muy difícil
no tiene ya como lo dijimos recién la
confianza de muchos de ellos el clan o
el grupo detrás de sunat es un grupo
también muy poderoso dentro del partido
van a ser los backpages no dentro del
parlamento inglés se van a encargar de
hacerle sentir el peso de sus opiniones
también a este gobierno Así que yo creo
que los pseudos los feudos internos del
partido no van a parar porque bajo
Johnson nunca lo fueron con desde que
salió Dominica hacia adelante Adiós
siempre
mucho revuelo por debajo Así que yo yo
lo que pienso estilistas va a tener que
tener mucho cuidado y no sé cómo va a
lograr operar una disciplina de partido
si es que no tiene esa confianza de las
élite
Esa es la gran pregunta que yo tengo
hablemos ahora de un tema que resurgió
Durante los últimos días que tiene que
ver con lo que ocurre entre los vínculos
entre Francia y Reino Unido no
recordemos aquel episodio que ocurrió
hace poco unos días cuando fue
consultada el historial sobre ese
presidente francés Emmanuel macron era
amigo o enemigo Ella dijo algo así como
que el Jurado lo estaba deliberando
todavía qué ocurre con estos vínculos
Carmen
son vínculos históricos hay que entender
que la relación siempre ha sido un poco
tensa a traer por un lado y el otro de
la Mancha yo creo que hay un malestar
muy grande
con el poderío de Francia dentro de la
Unión Europea es algo que les quedó muy
marcado a los que querían el brexit
[Música]
les recuerda el poder que tiene la Unión
Europea y en el fondo la primera
ministra en este caso va a querer
demostrar a toda costa de que la salida
de la Unión Europea valió la pena era lo
correcto y que Inglaterra se sostiene
por sí misma en este contexto
geopolítico
la relación con Francia yo creo que va a
tener que ser
recuperada la confianza recuperada de a
poco Aunque yo pienso que no hay mucha
Leslie Cuál es su punto de vista
respecto de este tema no estas
históricas relaciones que bueno como
decía Carmen no han sido fáciles que
proyección se puede hacer con listos
como primera ministra y con este
antecedente no estas declaraciones sobre
el presidente francés Emmanuel macron
yo creo que ya va a tener que asumir la
realidad del nuevo estatus del Reino
Unido en el concierto internacional
Yo creo que el Reino Unido a pesar de su
vocación de apoyo a Ucrania en forma
proactiva durante el mandato de Boris
Johnson creo que no se sostiene por sí
solo no se sostiene desde el Reino Unido
necesita de Aliado y los aliados más
importantes del Reino Unido en este caso
es la Unión Europea Más allá de Estados
Unidos e incluso y en ese contexto la
relación bilateral con Francia es
importante es histórica siempre se
muestran ciertos como ciertos aspectos
así de de competitividad entre Francia
y la tierra pero son más bien quizás más
anecdótico más folklórico por decirlo
parte de la cultura de la relación
bilateral pero
creo que con mis trabajos y con su
declaraciones ella ha dejado va a tener
que buscar recomponer esa
adoptar un rol de de de de del líder una
cosa es ser candidato otra cosa es estar
al mando de de de un estado en este caso
y ahí prima los carismático y la
necesidad y la viabilidad y ahí hay una
necesidad obvia del Reino Unido de tener
esta esta Alianza con con la Unión
Europea y ahí Francia es Poderosa
Carmen Sepúlveda bueno muchísimo se ha
hablado de la figura de margaret
thatcher no se la vinculó muchísimo a
litros Bueno de hecho en los últimos
días
se desmarcó un poco no de la ex primera
ministra qué similitudes y diferencias
podemos encontrar entre ambas
la verdad yo creo que se utilizó más la
imagen de Margarita yo creo que no son
tan parecidas
no tienen el mismo recorrido mucho
sentido
no están dentro de un mismo contexto
histórico para nada las crisis que les
van a tocar son muy diferentes
pero yo creo que para ella
usar la nostalgia que trae para el para
un sector conservador de una clase media
muy aspirante en Inglaterra era muy
importante era muy importante porque ahí
es donde está ese voto profundo ese voto
de las bases y al mismo tiempo se tenía
que
destacar un poco de ella porque por
ejemplo los bélico el conflicto con las
malvinas fue clave para amargar esta
para asegurarse y confirmarse como
siendo primera mujer Primer Ministro
como una una líder una líder esa sólida
en el caso detrás va a tener que
distanciarse por eso porque ya no puede
correr con digamos con colores propios
justamente por lo que nos referíamos
recién la Unión Europea sigue siendo el
referente y el Aliado más grande de del
Reino Unido en este momento y por otro
lado también yo creo que le toca lidiar
con las regiones cosa que no le tocó a
Margarita está en esos años todavía
lidiar con tanto con gales como con
Escocia y con Nicolás surgen que a todo
esto sigue en con la idea de llevar a
cabo un referendo por la independencia
de Escocia
entonces bueno yo creo que la imagen un
poquito de esa mujer dura halcón
etcétera va a tener que mitigarla un
poco para dar una unidad la imagen más
pragmática y más asequible a diálogo
y Leslie Qué opina usted son similitudes
concretas reales o quizás más del tipo
simbólicas
son simbólicas pero también fueron la
imagen que ella buscó proyectar hacia el
partido hacia la base del partido
conservador en esta elección obviamente
son distintas hay un contexto distinto
como lo mencionó Carmen
por un lado y el contexto pasa porque
hasta cierto punto con margaret thatcher
había cierta cierto consenso a nivel de
élite política de Buscar reformas
radicales en términos neoliberales de
reducir el tamaño del Estado actualmente
yo no sé si ese concepto el consenso
existe en la élite política y no creo
que exista a nivel nacional a base del
electorado más allá del electorado del
partido conservador
creo que hasta cierto punto después de
la herencia de creo que hay una herencia
de generar políticas sociales mucho más
robustas con un rol del estado más
fuerte y
que en eso la promesa de ella y es su
programa es bastante disonante con esa
realidad social y yo creo que hay se
diferencian bastante ya ahora obviamente
Tacher también
ella empezó Tuvo cuatro años de mandato
ya llegó el 79 fue bastante moderada el
año 79 y ella empieza con las
transformaciones económicas en el 80
hacia adelante y obviamente eso se
amplifica su popularidad con con el
resultado la guerra de las malvinas pero
acá atrás Tiene 18 meses
Entonces el tiempo el marco temporal
para ejecutar ciertas políticas para
generar consenso pero también generar
viabilidad para el partido conservador
en las elecciones creo que son desafíos
bastante grandes teniendo en cuenta
también que hay un desgaste en el
partido conservador ante la imagen del
electorado nacional o sea cuántos años
ya han estado en el poder eso genera un
desgaste
Leslie recién Carmen Sepúlveda
mencionaba un tema clave también que
genera afecciones tensiones introducía
el tema de Escocia quisiera preguntarle
bueno Escocia Está bueno planteando no
un nuevo referendo independentista listo
listo se adelantó que nunca permitiría y
la voy a citar que la familia británica
Se separe aumentarán más aún las
tensiones Leslie en este aspecto
no puedo escuchar mi pregunta la puedo
escuchar Carmen
sí Yo escucho la pregunta
entonces
[Música]
yo creo que no va a poder
controlar lo que pasa en Escocia así
siempre hay el devolution no la de
vuelta de poder hacia estas naciones
dentro del Reino Unido fue muy
importante la presencia del parlamento
Pero además la relación que ha
desarrollado Escocia con la Unión
Europea
no veo cómo podrían controlar desde
Londres lo que haga Escocia sobre todo
viendo cómo han tratado el tema de
Irlanda yo creo que Escocia estamos le
falta o sea tiene muy poca confianza en
lo que viene de Londres y bueno el
Nicolás no respondió le dijo que no
estaban de acuerdo al casi nada y van a
tener que tratar de trabajar juntos
Así que yo creo que por ahí va a ser
difícil
Leslie Bueno nos queda muy poco tiempo
pero le quiero trasladar esta misma
pregunta no sobre este referendo
independentista que quiere hacer Escocia
electroasio pone rotundamente las
tensiones en ese aspecto se
profundizarán
[Música]
salió fortalecida
en el liderazgo para atravesar la crisis
eso generó mayor apoyo a su partido a su
liderazgo a su visión y
obviamente ella va a tratar de cabal de
capitalizar esta esta demanda Y eso va a
generar valor encriptación y
confrontación con el gobierno de
nos queda solo un minuto de programa
quiero aprovecharlo para consultarle
sobre sus respectivas conclusiones
tienen 30 segundos cada uno Carmen
Sepúlveda conclusiones sobre qué le
espera a Reino Unido
yo la verdad
veo con mucha preocupación lo que se
viene porque si bien son solo un año y
medio antes de las próximas elecciones
en un año mayor también se pueden hacer
muchas cosas esto no fue una elección
general lo que le impide llegar con un
programa muy comprensivo a Alice Trust
pero viene con ciertas ideas que yo creo
que pueden ser bien nefastas lo que
podría mediar esto es que labels siga
ganando votos o sea o intenciones de
votos en las encuestas dándole obligando
al gobierno detrás acercarse digamos más
directas
no sé por darte un ejemplo muy muy burdo
pero el costo de la energía en las
escuelas va a ser un temazo Leslie sus
conclusiones nos quedan tan solo 30
segundos perdón
también Creo que se viene bastante
difícil para ella con la crisis
económica por la inflación por los
precios de energía y también por por las
medidas que son disonantes a este
contexto económico y que va a ser
capitalizado y puede ser capitalizado
por el partido laborista
bueno llegamos al final del debate de
Franz 24 agradecemos muchísimo la
presencia de Carmen Sepúlveda y de
Leslie benac Venegas y también por
supuesto como siempre a nuestra
audiencia le invitamos a que sigan
informándose en el resto de nuestra
programación y también en transmite
4.com 100 junto a nosotros
[Música]